[Music]
jaquail night is the creative mind
behind many of Beyonce's iconic
performances he's worked with her for
years and he's been dancing his entire
life I remember dancing in my
grandmother's living room at ages 4 by
copying the things I saw on TV as I got
older I remember copying all the major
iconic of MTV Award shows performances
new Soul Train performances and then
when I was 16 I started my own dance
group with my best friend in Atlanta so
that was kind of the first serious step
towards choreography and creative
direction at just 18 jaquail landed a
gig choreographing one of the best
videos of all time
single ladies Frank Gatson junior who
was choreographer creative director for
Beyonce and Destiny's Child for you know
ages he was actually working on Michelle
Williams debut project in the process of
that he was like wow you know how to
teach you know how to deal with people
you eat really well you know how about
you come on board and help choreograph
the video with us and the netsuke was
like can you come choreograph the entire
trouble to the poor and then a few
months went by he call it was like yo I
have this Beyonce record can you fly to
New York tonight
I was like yeah got to New York
the record was single ladies once
getting in his face with her you know
I'm starting to dance with her and see
how she thinks and move through the
project and how she see things they're a
hit you know I was completely blown away
ten years later jaquail and Beyonce
teamed up for yet another iconic
performance they incorporated homecoming
moves made popular by historically black
colleges and universities
Beyonce kind of woke up with one day it
was like yo let's do this homecoming
this means you know the research behind
it you know we went back and watched you
know football games
you watch home comments so many probates
watch eternities in the club watch
sororities we've watched a load of just
black college experiences and then kind
of got in the mindset of creating the
right energy I wish I could count the
hours you know that put into a bit you
know but we worked for like five or six
months on it working with me during the
rehearsal process is like it's kind of
out-of-body experience you know people
don't understand the amount of effort
our work ethic is out of this world and
has never just one thing you know when
recreating a choreography is okay boom
where it's wardrobe you know bring them
in so they can see what the choreography
is okay boom where are we on the stage
you know let's make sure lighting knows
how to light this boom where are the
cameras okay let's look at this camera
and then do this you know we're always
thinking of every single piece of the
puzzle so just to see that her mind
understands every part of putting the
show together and she remembers and she
know all of her marks and she know all
of her lyrics and how she's gonna saying
everything you know she's really in
there getting it you know asking
questions you're doing it a hundred
times you know so we spend a lot of time
in in the dance studio making sure that
these things come off fill it like
nothing
[Music]